[Music]
foreign
I fear this will not be a kind place to
such a boy
boy has talent but one in particular
that is exceptional very well
[Music]
I realized the more I sailed the less I
was alone
you always so competitive
[Applause]
[Music]
the show-off who spoiled Mozart's
concert May I play with you monsieur
I hope this won't be embarrassing for
you
who the hell is that
you are quite a remarkable man
I'm Marie Antoinette queen of France
hereby anoint you Chevalier any other
country man of your color would not be
wearing such fine clothes one day the
whole world will know me and of course
the music will be spectacular
bold
you don't belong here you're a party
trick repet playing the violin that is
all
you know why the best
you were playing a dangerous game friend
you forget your place but break his
hands
this world is painful for us my son but
there is always a choice to fight I am
putting on a concept let us fund the
revolution
you cannot afford to make any more
enemies
France is changing you could be more
influential than you know leverage it
if you take to the stage you will be
erased Filipino new front you cannot
topple what has been ordained by God
not everything is about you people
foreign
[Music]